[Musique]
j'ai commencé la lutte en 2017 voilà à
l'âge de 18 ans 2 mois après on m'a dit
qu'il y aura le choix de la Francophonie
ici à Abidjan j'ai dit voilà pourquoi ne
pas tenter ma chance
la petite différence qu'il y a entre la
lutte africaine et la lutte ou le pire
c'est que la lutte africaine se déroule
dans le sable et là on demande juste les
trois appuis pour avoir la victoire
une bonne muqueuse il faut être
technicienne il faut avoir la technicité
en soi il faut avoir l'envie voilà faut
avoir l'envie parce que si tu n'as pas
l'envie ça c'est ça ne sert à rien tout
ce que tu vas faire il faut avoir
l'amour de ce que tu veux faut voir
l'amour parce que c'est c'est le plus
difficile si tu n'aimes pas quelque
chose qu'on te force ou pas tu vas
jamais y arriver et moi j'ai l'amour de
la chose
[Musique]
c'est un peu compliqué parce que en Côte
d'Ivoire
d'abord l'école parce que les parents de
début n'ont pas voulu donc il faut se
cacher aller passer par là c'est pas
compliqué les entraînements de la parce
qu'on traîne je crois une ou deux fois
par semaine et c'est vraiment très peu
de pouvoir affronter ces gens de
compétition c'est très difficile
l'entraînement là-bas
la pression était vraiment trop depuis
le début jusqu'à maintenant parce que je
suis la première à passer dans toutes
les compétitions je suis la première
donc la pression je sens la la la charge
de mes amis sur mes épaules ça dit je
suis je suis comme une porte pour que
les autres puissent entrer donc il me
faut aller jusqu'à fond et c'est ce que
j'ai fait
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de travail à faire
encore après ces médailles là c'est
vraiment rien du tout ceci ça c'est rien
il faut encore aller au-delà de vous
même pour être qualifié pour les JO